Hi, I'm Kobig from
the Google Play team.
Every developer dreams of their
app going big, really big.
The key is making an app
that users really love.
If you reach out,
listen, and respond,
you can grow your community.
First, you need to make an app
that people will really want.
Does it entertain them, help
them be more productive?
It's important to figure out
who is your target customer.
Reach out.
A passionate group
of early adopters
can be really important
to refining your app
and helping you gain traction.
Figure out who those people
are and where those people go--
social media, blogs,
conferences, whatever.
In Korea, we've
heard from developers
that, because they are
attracting PC gamers,
they go to public
forums for PC gamers
to announce upcoming games.
We've also heard from developers
about using a local agency
or hiring a community manager
to reach out to their users.
Listen!
Once you've identified
the people who
can't wait to try your
app, talk to them.
Get information about
what they're looking for.
Get their feedback on your
early ideas and prototypes.
Set up a Google group
or a Google+ community,
so that your users
can talk to you.
If your app is a secret,
make the group private.
Shhhh.
Listen!
When you're first version
is ready to test, publish
to alpha or beta testers
and collect feedback.
Why are there are
two different groups?
Well, you may want to test the
earliest version with a trusted
group of friends and
family as an alpha test.
Tell them to beware of bugs.
When there's enough
positive feedback,
push your version to a
larger group of beta testers.
And when your app
is ready, ship it.
Recognize the contribution of
your alpha and beta testers.
Mention specific new features
in your product updates.
Reply directly to user
posts in the community.
And add a special thanks
section to your game credits.
Users love to see the
impact of their feedback.
So now you have a great
app, a passionate group
of early adopters, and your
app is starting to take off.
What's next?
Well, you'll want
to figure out what
users are doing in your app.
An easy and free
way to do that is
to integrate Google
Analytics into your app.
It's part of the Google
Play Services SDK
and can be enabled with
just a single line of code.
You can see how many people
use your app on a daily basis.
And you can even track what
parts of your app people
use most.
Once you've hooked
up Google Analytics,
you can link it up with the
Google Play Developer Console.
If you do this, you'll see
your new users and active users
directly in the Dev console.
All of this data will help
you tweak how your app works
and make sure that you're
investing the most in ways
to reach new users.
Make sure there
are ways in the app
to encourage users to
invite their friends.
When we ask users how
they find new apps,
one of the most common
reasons they mention
is hearing about
it from a friend.
Find good ways to reward users
who invite others to join in.
Respond!
New apps aren't perfect.
We've all seen bugs before.
Show your users that you care
and respond to the issues
they raise.
Make sure that there
are clear ways for users
to report problems both on
your Google Play store listing
and within your app.
And be sure to respond
quickly to user questions.
Google Play allows you to
respond to user reviews,
and your responses are
displayed on the Play store.
Any future users who
visit your store listing
will see how responsive
you are to users,
and that you're committed
to improving your app.
User reviews will
help you figure out
what parts of your app
need the most improvement.
By being responsive, you'll
see your user ratings improve.
As you get more reviews,
analyzing your users' sentiment
is important.
This is why soon we will allow
you to download your user
reviews for the Dev console.
To protect users
against a bad experience
and to protect your reviews,
you can also use staged rollout
to release new versions to only
a percentage of your users.
So if there's a bug, you
can find out and fix it
before it hits everyone.
You can also let
users know what's
going on with your latest
version by updating the what's
new text of your new APK.
Making sure that your current
users are happy and engaged
is the best way to further
grow your user base,
because happy users
spread the word.
As you continue to add
new features to your app,
working with beta testers,
responding to user feedback,
and seeing how users
react to your changes,
will help you create
a community of users
who are passionate
about your app.
Here at the Google
Play team, we hope
you have great success
building your user community.